j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
dans ce sens public sur la mixité
sociale à l'école Papin Ndiaye recevait
aujourd'hui les recteurs d'académie pour
leur donner des objectifs en la matière
avant de voir pourquoi le ministre a
renoncé à l'annonce d'un plan ambitieux
un exemple d'établissement privé qui
lutte contre la ségrégation en ouvrant
ses portes aux élèves boursiers Mathias
ici nous sommes au collège avec une
place de quatrième et une classe de 3e
qui sont en anglais avec dans cette
classe ciboursier sur 15 qui fait plutôt
30% de boursiers l'institution du
sacré-cœur de Breteuil fait figure de
très bon élève en matière de mixité
sociale Alain Blaise Vasse directeur du
collège il voit une mission c'est
l'accueil de tous et le vivre ensemble
qui nous semble important sur la mixité
sociale sur 87 élèves au collège 22
bénéficient de bourse ou d'exonération
de frais de scolarité soit 25% des
effectifs en comptant les élèves du
primaire plus de 50% des 259 enfants
sont concernés donc s'il faut accueillir
plus de boursiers pourquoi pas ça ne ça
ne me pose pas de de questions en tout
cas sur institution dont je dirige
au contraire au contraire certains comme
Raphaël et Gabriel boursiers et
scolarisés ici depuis leur plus jeune
âge apprécient le cadre pédagogique
offert par l'établissement privé moi
j'aime bien cette école parce que avec
il y a mes amis que je connais il y en a
quelques-uns que je connais depuis bien
longtemps et après oui il y a des
professeurs qui sont là depuis aussi
longtemps donc
ils nous connaissent il y a pas beaucoup
de monde alors
si on connaît on les connaît tout le
monde il y a il n'y a pas de problème
au niveau
du respect chez le corps enseignant le
constat est unanime la mixité est une
richesse pour les élèves et ça nourrice
effectivement de leurs différences
expériences et l'avantage de
l'établissement c'est qu'il fonctionne
véritablement comme un creuser vous avez
des enfants de différentes origines
différentes différents milieux en
quelque sorte mais qui sont unis grâce
au fait que l'établissement est assez
petit
et qu'une équipe pédagogique permet de
les encadrer correctement donc la mixité
sociale en réalité au bout d'un moment
elle est tellement présente qu'on ne la
voit plus une expérience qui tire tout
le monde vers le haut moi j'ai déjà
constaté vu que j'ai fréquenté j'ai
renseigné aussi bien dans l'éducation
nationale que dans l'enseignement
agricole que dans le privé et dans
l'établissement je suis actuellement
effectivement les différences sociales
me sautent moi aux yeux à travers les
résultats et à travers les méthodes de
travail infra subsiste toutefois pour
aller vers plus de mixité sociale au
sein des écoles privées les frais de
cantine non subventionnés ils
représentent parfois autant voire plus
que le coût de la scolarité elle-même et
pour débattre autour de ce thème de
mixité sociale de ségrégation sociale à
l'école j'accueille Xavier akovelli
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine Claire
Mazeron bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
directrice académique des services de
l'éducation nationale de Paris Youssef
WiDi bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes docteur
en économie chercheur au CNRS à
l'Université Paris Dauphine euh écoute
avec Julien Grenet d'un rapport sur la
ségrégation sociale dans les collèges
parisiens avec nous également en duplex
Gilles de Marquet qui est président de
l'association de parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement libre l'appel bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi et Guillaume
d'arrêt évidemment est resté à mes côtés
je voudrais pour commencer un premier
tour de table sur cet exemple qu'on
vient de voir dans notre reportage donc
on a plus d'un tiers d'élèves boursier
dans un établissement privé Xavier
yakovelli on se dit pourquoi pas un peu
partout en France l'exemple à suivre oui
la mixité sociale il faut qu'elle soit à
la fois dans le public et si on parlera
peut-être de la carte scolaire parfois
qui est quand on est parents on voit
toujours le meilleur pour son enfant
donc il peut être compréhensible d'un
point de vue de parents un peu moins
quand on est d'un point de vue des
pouvoirs publics et puis il y a aussi la
mixité sociale qui doit s'organiser dans
le privé et c'est tout l'engagement de
la convention qui a été signé entre
l'éducation nationale et et l'éducation
libre donc je pense que d'ailleurs
inédit ça fait 20 ans je crois que nous
n'avons pas eu de signature d'une
convention ou d'un nouveau contrat entre
l'éducation privée et l'éducation
nationale et donc je pense que ça va
dans bon sens mais on va voir jusqu'où
le l'éducation privée les les
établissements privés sont prêts à jouer
Jeu clair Mazon dans votre action à
travers de la mixité sociale est-ce que
déjà pour bien comprendre vous avez la
main sur les collèges et lycées privés
ou pas du tout comment ça se passe il y
a des lycées sous contrat donc
à la main sur son recrutement ça fait
partie de ses prérogatives donc on peut
être évidemment qu'un citatif l'action
qu'on peut avoir c'est sur le nombre
d'autorisation de classe pour ouvrir
pour fermer là-dessus on a une action
mais c'est vrai que le privé a sa pleine
liberté de choix des des élèves est-ce
que c'est difficile Youssef se dit de
d'intégrer les établissements privés
dans une politique de mixité sociale
parce que là on a donné un bon exemple
mais ce qu'il y en a tant que ça bah
c'est un exemple qu'il faudrait pas
qu'il cache la forêt de tous les
enseignements privés
écoutez ce que j'aurais reprendrai
là-dessus je crois que l'exemple que
l'on a vu et est assez révélateur de ce
qui se passe dans beaucoup d'endroits de
l'enseignement catholique
certes si je reprends un peu
l'historique de l'enseignement
catholique
la présence géographique et
historiquement dans les centres villes
mais également dans la ruralité avec
l'école de monsieur le curé qui a été
ouverte au 19e siècle mais la présence
dans les périphéries des grandes villes
est assez faible dans la mesure où vous
savez que depuis 40 ans il y a eu
beaucoup de déplacements de population
de gens qui sont partis de la campagne
pour aller dans les périphéries des
grandes villes et puis on a vu aussi que
dans les grandes villes il y a eu aussi
des gens qui sont partis bon nous allons
beaucoup de Parisiens autour de la table
c'est vrai que Paris n'est pas la France
et on peut constater quand même que sur
Paris
pris de l'immobilier qui a fortement cru
depuis une dizaine d'années
est un frein pour un certain nombre de
familles qui ont fait le choix de
quitter Paris dans ce qui fait qu'il
faut quand même avoir certains moyens
pour vivre dans Paris et l'établissement
que vous avez vu
est un établissement en ruralité mais
vous avez plein d'établissements de ce
type il faut pas se cacher derrière ce
qui existe en centre-ville mais pour
répondre à ce qui était dit je voudrais
quand même rappeler quels sont les
motivations de d'une famille pour
inscrire un enfant dans l'établissement
quelqu'un l'a dit chacun chaque parent
veut le meilleur pour son enfant donc
ils vont un cadre qui lui permet pardon
je vais vous interdire je vais vous
interrompre je pense que vous m'entendez
parce que je pardonne nous interrompre
j'essaie de le faire le moins possible
mais là vous étiez parti dans une longue
démonstration je préfère revenir à un
point précis que nous donnait Youssef
WiDi vous entendez sur le les critères
de recrutement parce que c'est vous
étiez en train de nous dire pourquoi une
famille choisie d'aller dans un
établissement privé dans un
établissement catholique si
effectivement vous avez 200 candidats
pour 100 places
quels sont les critères de recrutement
et pourquoi ne sont-ils pas finalement
accessibles au public
alors
la manière dont on se passe l'entrée
d'une famille dans l'enseignement
catholique elle se fait déjà par une
rencontre une rencontre entre la famille
et le chef d'établissement pour parler
du projet éducatif de l'établissement et
parce qu'il faut qu'il adhésion à ce
projet je crois que on a la liberté de
choix en France pour chaque famille de
choisir entre le public le privé
éventuellement l'instruction à la maison
et je crois que c'est heureux qu'il y
ait cette liberté de choix pour chaque
famille de choisir le mode éducatif pour
leurs enfants dans donc cette rencontre
est extrêmement importante et faut pas
croire que un chef d'établissement va
faire un recrutement par rapport aux
revenus de la famille pas du tout bon il
va le faire par rapport à la motivation
par rapport à ce qu'il va rencontrer de
cette famille est-ce que cette famille
va pouvoir lui dire mais il y a pas
spécialement de critères de grille
administrative qui puisse exister à mon
sens bon alors on y reviendra dans un
instant pour ce qu'on est on est au
stade du constat dans ce dans ce débat
je vais quand même donner quelques
chiffres qui nous viennent du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale sur la
proportion d'élèves alors les termes
employés par le ministère ces
proportions d'élèves de milieu
défavorisés et on est allé regarder
quels étaient les ce que représentaient
cette catégorie ouvriers ou inactif on
est à 42,6 % d'élèves de milieu
défavorisés dans le public pour 18% à
peine tout petit peu plus dans le privé
et puis alors si on inverse le le prisme
le regard proportion d'élèves de milieu
favoriser dans cette catégorie on met
enseignant cadre supérieur chefs
d'entreprise de 10 salariés ou plus et
professions libérale vous voyez les
chiffres 19,5% d'élèves de milieu
favorisés dans le public 40% dans le
privé pour je reste dans le constat pour
évaluer établissement par établissement
le niveau de mixité il y a un acronyme
que vous n'avez pas encore utilisé mais
qui va falloir bien maîtriser dans ce
débat c'est
IPS et je propose à terme traduit de
venir nous expliquer ce qu'il
tonton se douter un mec qui aujourd'hui
est statistiquement documenté pour tout
le monde alors quelques chiffres encore
si vous prenez les 100 collèges à l'IPS
le plus élevé et bien vous avez 81 %
d'établissement privé l'IPS manière des
collèges il est aujourd'hui de
103,36 et bien la palme revient au
collège franco-allemand de Buc dans les
Yvelines collège privé avec un score de
157,6 le plus bas c'est le collège grand
Mandy fou en Guyane ça donne aussi une
idée de la fracture territoriale un
collège public avec un indice lui de
47,5 et globalement les IPs les plus
élevées se retrouvent surtout dans les
collèges privés situés dans les grandes
agglomérations c'est ce que vous avez
dit le 1er mars d'ailleurs et bien lors
d'un débat sur la mixité sociale au
Sénat Papen Ndiaye avait reconnu que
rendre public l'IPS avait ses vertus
écoutez je note la bonne disposition de
nos interlocuteurs du privé sous contrat
parce que
les temps ont changé aussi la
publication des IPS a joué aussi son
rôle et nous avons quelques moyens de
pression si je puis dire nous pouvons
agir puisque les moyens
d'enseignement l'allocation de poste
lorsque des demandes sont faites par le
privé sous contrat peut aussi être un
facteur de pression si je puis dire sur
les établissements de manière à ce que
il s'engage dans des politiques résolues
de mixité sociale et scolaire et la
publication de cette indice de
publication sociale ça a aussi donné
lieu à une initiative au Sénat et oui
celle du sénateur communiste pierre
ouzoulia qui souhaite clairement
conditionner les financements du privé à
des critères de mixité sociale
aujourd'hui rappelons que l'État finance
les salaires des enseignants dans le
privé et les collectivités contribuent
au frais de fonctionnement de ces
établissements le budget des écoles
privées
trois quarts des financements publics le
sénateur communiste propose donc de
moduler les crédits affectés au
fonctionnement comme ceux des salaires à
la mixité sociale alors quand on écoute
le ministre de l'éducation nationale on
comprend que Papen DIY ne serait
personnellement pas contre mais le texte
n'a absolument aucune chance d'être
adopté par le Sénat merci à votre avis
là-dessus Xavier est-ce qu'il faut
conditionner les subventions du privé à
des critères de mixité moi je crois à la
négociation et c'est ce qui est en cours
et c'est ce qui est déjà été signé pour
accueillir on parlait de mixité donc du
coup d'accueillir plus de boursiers et
plus de d'élèves défavorisés comme le
ministère peut les intitulé ce type
d'élèves je pense que c'est il faut
aller dans ce sens là elle est dans une
négociation il est pas question de
rentrer en confrontation entre le privé
et public je pense que ça c'est une
autre époque et je crois plutôt à la
concertation et à la négociation de
coercition mais il faut aussi être clair
73% ça a été rappelé
73% aujourd'hui
du fonctionnement du privé et financé
par des fonds publics à la fois par les
salaires des professeurs et par les
coûts de fonctionnement par les
collectivités locales je parle
uniquement du privé sous contrat donc
oui il faut que dans cette négociation
il y a aussi une reconnaissance de la
part du public du financement public
dans le fonctionnement du privé et donc
il y a un effort du privé pour
accueillir plus de mixité et plus
d'enfants défavorisés alors ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui c'est que donc le
ministre papounia il a reçu les
réacteurs d'académie on s'attendait et
si on organise des bas aujourd'hui c'est
aussi pour ça on s'attendait à l'annonce
d'un grand plan ministériel
on est là pour ça sur la mixité sociale
puis ça s'est transformé en boîte à
outils sont les termes sont nos
confrères du monde qui racontent
ambition revue à la baisse notamment sur
l'ambition sur l'enseignement privé
pardon le ministre qui donne une boîte à
outils au recteurs pour le public on est
loin du plan d'ensemble
est-ce qu'il y a là quoi c'est une
ambition
qui doit à laquelle il doit renoncer
parce qu'il n'a pas réussi à convaincre
le secteur privé qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il y a aussi à regarder les
chiffres puisqu'on parle de chiffres
aujourd'hui le privé c'est 17 % des
élèves 80% pour pour le public donc
toutes les annonces que nous mettons en
place depuis le début du quinquennat
concerne principalement le public et
parce que c'est là la vraie fracture
aussi à la fois territoriale les la
question d'évitement et la mixité
sociale elle se fait d'abord sur les
écoles publiques et ensuite il y a
effectivement cette négociation qu'on
doit avoir et qui a eu lieu déjà depuis
la fin 2022 avec le privé pour arriver à
plus de mixité sociale dans les écoles
privées mais je pense que la priorité
effectivement ce sont les 80% de nos
élèves qui sont scolarisés dans le monde
évidemment venir aux solutions qu'on
peut mettre en place dans le public mais
j'aurais puisque c'est notre premier
chapitre on l'a bien compris la question
du privé vous vous entendez là-dessus
cette proposition de du sénateur
communiste puis à Oulia c'est voilà
conditionné les subventions aux critères
de mixité vous dites allons-y banco même
si on l'a compris il y a très peu de
chances que ça je peux dire allons-y
mais je suis assez sceptique sur le fait
que ça se fasse bon mais effectivement
mais c'est vrai que le privé c'est 20%
des élèves mais une note du service
statistique du ministère l'été dernier
montrait que là où dans les départements
ou la ségrégation a augmenté c'est du
fait du privé et privé qui a une
composition sociale de plus en plus
favorisée et c'est de le cas de manière
continue depuis des années 80 et on
arrive quoi juste pour bien comprendre
pas être trop technique si un
établissement privé s'installe quelque
part la ségrégation augmente c'est
plutôt on va dire que
il y a la même répartition des
établissements cela dit c'est comment
dire la composition sociale entre public
et privé c'est de plus en plus
différencié c'est-à-dire que le fameux
favorisées ont de plus en plus recours
au privé et tout à l'heure vous montriez
l'écart de composition sociale entre
public et privées que le privé
accueillait plus de familles favorisées
que le public et c'est cet écart qui a
augmenté c'est en train d'augmenter
alors sur cette question des subventions
je vous propose une réaction un
témoignage celui du sénateur socialiste
des Français de l'étranger il y a une
chanterey c'était ici au Sénat en séance
publique le 1er mars dernier voilà ce
qu'il propose c'est mon privé sous
contrat est subventionné par l'État et
les collectivités territoriales à
hauteur de 73 % c'est près de 10
milliards d'euros qui chaque année
sortent des caisses publiques pour
financer le privé alors que le public
souffre d'un manque de moyens chroniques
le privé continue de profiter de
nouveaux effets d'aubaine comme avec la
loi Carl en 2009 et la loi blancaire en
2019 or k unique au monde ce financement
public du privé se fait pratiquement
sans aucune contrepartie
ces établissements échappent à la carte
scolaire et leur recrutement reste
opaque on ne sait pas quel critère sont
retenus pour sélectionner les élèves
tout le monde finance le privé mais tout
le monde n'y a pas accès tout le monde
finance le privé mais tout le monde n'y
a pas accès je retiens cette cette
conclusion de Yann chanterelle et je
viens vers vous évidemment Gilles de
Marquet pour entendre votre réponse
là-dessus il y a effectivement 10
milliards d'euros par an qui sortent des
caisses de l'État pour le pour les
établissements privés est-ce que ça
serait pas logique que ces subventions
soient conditionnées à plus de mixité
alors c'est c'est en effet il y a de
l'argent qui sort des caisses de l'État
qui vient également de tous les
contribuables que nous sommes vous comme
moi qui finance tout le système éducatif
qui soit public ou qu'il soit privé
est-ce que ça serait logique oui moi je
voudrais mettre en avant quand même et
ça a été dit dans le premier reportage
quand vous avez été voir le collège sur
certains freins et il y a un frein qui
est extrêmement important qui est celui
de la cantine et des frais de
restauration pourquoi parce que quand
vous avez une famille qui paie un euro
le repas dans le dans le public elle va
le payer beaucoup plus cher dans
l'enseignement privé parce que si elle
exerce la liberté de choix d'aller à
l'enseignement primaire ben elle ne va
perdre haras de raserception près cette
cette aide sociale donc peut-elle
vraiment exercer sa liberté de choix et
choisir d'aller dans le segment privé si
jamais elle perd le bénéfice des aides
sociales là c'est une vraie question et
faudrait plus de subventions pour
financer les cantines pardon pardon nous
interrompre c'est toujours désagréable
quand les voix se chevauchent mais ça
vous dit quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait plus de subventions pour
pouvoir financer les l'accès aux
cantines dans les établissements privés
juste pour bien comprendre ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que chaque famille qui si
est scolaris son enfant dans le public
bénéficie d'un tarif social à 1 euro
parce qu'elle est d'un milieu très
défavorisé puisse également bénéficier
du même tarif de la même aide sociale si
elle le scolarise dans l'enseignement
privé je rappelle pardonnez-moi il faut
savoir aussi que la question du
périscolaire les communes ont la
possibilité de financer déjà le
périscolaire pour les écoles privées
sous contrat de l'heure de leur commune
donc la question de la cantine scolaire
peut déjà rentrer dans le cadre de
financement dans le cadre de
conventionnement entre l'école privée
sous contrat et la collectivité locale
donc il y a pas besoin de changer la loi
ou de faire évoluer la réglementation
c'est négociation entre la collectivité
locale et l'école
une réaction un autre aspect un autre de
la citation de Yann chanterelle quand il
dit que le privé échappe à la carte
scolaire oui alors c'est la loi
maintenant c'est vrai que la question
des subventions c'est une partie de la
question mais ça n'occupe pas la
question de l'affectation des élèves
entre du recrutement qu'on a abordé au
départ c'est-à-dire que ça très bien été
dit à partir du moment où il y a plus de
demandes que d'offres il faut des
critères on le sait très bien parce que
dans certains établissements publics je
vais parler d'Henri Ivry Legrand
jusqu'au moment où on a modifié
l'affectation l'année dernière les
critères quand on a beaucoup de demandes
c'est d'abord des critères scolaires les
critères scolaires sont très fortement
corrélés aux critères sociaux en termes
de réussite des élèves c'est ce que
mesure d'ailleurs l'IPS donc à un moment
donné la question qui se pose c'est
certes d'attirer des boursiers mais
c'est aussi il faut le dire de de ne pas
favoriser la fuite des familles
favorisées vers le ça marche dans les
deux sens il ne faut pas non plus en
incitant les familles moins favorisées à
candidater dans le privé n'attirer que
les meilleurs boursiers parce qu'à Paris
on avait cette problématique avant la
réforme qu'on a conduit c'est à dire que
on avait des taux de boursiers dans les
lycées très favorisés qui étaient plutôt
intéressant autour de 25 30 %. mais
c'était les meilleurs boursiers en
termes de niveau scolaire il s'est pris
au lycée public il s'est publique un
lycée comme Charlemagne 29% de boursiers
mais un IPS à 145 donc il faut faire
très attention entre mixité sociale
mixité scolaire et ne pas considérer
finalement que faire de la mixité dans
les lycées privés c'est uniquement
amener des boursiers qu'est-ce que vous
avez changé par exemple à Louis Legrand
dans ces établissements Henri IV enfin
voilà ultra prestigieux de Paris la
réflexion parce que ça peut être
complexe technique mais le lycées Louis
le Grand Henri IV échappé on va dire à
la règle commune des lycées parisiens
qui étaient l'affectation par un
algorithme à fenêtre et il est
proviseurs recrutaient directement les
élèves sur dossiers il y avait plusieurs
biais euh c'est à dire que le dépôt d'un
dossier la constitution d'un dossier
d'une lettre de motivation à l'entrée en
seconde on n'est pas dans le parcoursup
c'est une procédure que les familles
défavorisées ne font pas donc déjà dans
le vivier des candidats c'est un petit
peu ce qui se passe dans le privé c'est
à dire que au-delà de la question de
subventionner la cantine de réduire les
frais de scolarité la démarche d'aller
candidater dans un établissement c'est
pas automatique pour une famille qui est
assez éloignée de l'école donc là quand
on parle de Louis Logan
en tout cas c'est présenté comme tel 2
du public et donc il y a des familles
qui n'y vont pas quoi même pas la
débarque
de constitution d'un dossier trop
compliqué qui n'osait pas là il y a plus
qu'un seul vœu à faire dans la felnet
donc déjà c'est beaucoup plus simple et
ensuite il y avait un certain nombre de
billets dans l'examen d'un dossier parce
que quand vous regardez c'est pas
anonyme un élève qui vient d'un collège
du 18e et un élève qui vient d'un
collège du centre de Paris les
proviseurs de l'élogan et Henri IV leur
connu eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que on va
pas apporter le même regard sur la
petite remarque sur le bavardage pour
les du collège du 18e donc il y a un
biais dans le traitement humain des
dossiers aussi donc la procédure qu'on a
mise en place qui est une procédure
anonymnisée
assez équitable puisqu'on utilise un
barème scolaire qui est valable pour
tous les élèves harmoniser qui
harmonisent des différences de notation
entre collèges ça a quand même permis de
doubler en un an le nombre de boursiers
en récapitule le grand on est passé de
alors pour le coup les meilleurs
boursiers parce qu'en effet il y a
tellement de demandes sur ces deux
établissements qui a un taux de pression
important mais malgré tout sur les
autres lycées pour lesquels on avait
fait une réforme l'année précédente on
envoie on va dire des élèves de profil
scolaire boursiers plus diversifié bon
alors on va peut-être un peu plus se
concentrer sur le public maintenant et
sur cette question de la carte scolaire
parce que vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure vous aviez à covidia les
principes les valeurs que qu'une famille
peut peut porter et puis la réalité de
parents qui veulent éviter ce qu'on
appelle notamment des collèges ghetto
pour leurs enfants je vous propose une
démonstration un témoignage je suis du
proviseur du collège Berlioz dans l'état
Paris qui a vécu cette situation des
moyens pour contourner la carte scolaire
en écoute
la particularité du collège Hector
Berlioz ça a été progressivement
l'évitement d'une d'une partie de des
familles environ une famille sur trois
au profit d'autres établissements par
dérogation ou bien des établissements
privés la crainte pour bon nombre de
familles notamment les plus favorisées
c'est le nivellement vers le bas du
niveau scolaire
donc par manque de stimulation en
quelque sorte et un climat scolaire
dégradé voilà extrait du documentaire le
collège d'à côté qui avait été diffusé
sur notre antenne sur Public Sénat le 22
septembre dernier et pour bien vous
contextualiser depuis la rentrée 2019
les collèges de ce lycées parisien
Berlioz qualifié de ghetto je mets des
guillemets on verra on pourra en
reparler accueille ceux d'un collège
proche s'appelle quasbox peut-être
pardon pour la prononciation qui est
plus favorisée Youssef sweedy on appelle
ça je crois les binômes de collège ça
c'est une bonne idée ça quel bilan vous
en faites alors c'était l'objet du
rapport que vous avez cité au départ et
que j'ai écrit avec Julien Grenet et
l'idée de ces secteurs multicolores
c'est de dire qu'on a parfois des
collèges proches géographiquement mais
la composition sociale très différente
et donc tous les élèves en difficulté
et les de l'autre et là c'était les deux
collèges étaient à 5 minutes à pied à
peu près donc c'est vraiment une
proximité très importante et l'idée
c'est de dire que par exemple la rentrée
2019 tous les élèves puisque on n'a pas
on n'a pas rappelé mais c'est à dire
qu'il y a la carte scolaire en France et
étant donné mon adresse si j'ai un
enfant qui a 11 ans qui est entré en 6e
mon enfant est affecté un collège public
donc il y a deux secteurs différents
pour ces deux collèges on a fusionné ces
deux secteurs et on a dit à la rentrée
2019 par exemple tous les collèges vont
dans l'un des deux tous les élèves vont
dans l'un des deux collèges ils y font
l'ensemble de leur scolarité et l'année
suivante ils vont dans l'autre collège
ils y font l'ensemble de leur scolarité
et donc on a réuni des élèves de
quartier très différents socialement
dans un même collège
ça marche oui ça marche alors il y a
toujours
comprendre il y a toujours beaucoup de
peur de réticences de la part des
familles et la mise en place des
secteurs multicolores à Paris a été
assez violentes comme la réforme à felda
d'ailleurs après j'allais dire quand on
entend plus parler c'est à dire ça se
passe bien et je crois que ça se passe
bien donc c'est une expérience qui était
intéressante à Paris parce que on a 174
collèges sur un territoire très réduit
et avec une ségrégation qui s'exprime
parfois d'une rue à l'autre donc on peut
faire des couplages de collège après
c'est vrai que la difficulté quand on
prend un collège ou deux collèges c'est
que les parents vous disent toujours
finalement mais pourquoi nous et
pourquoi est-ce que finalement vous ne
le faites pas leur soit grande échelle
soit sur le collège d'à côté donc il y a
toujours de très fortes réticences faut
être très pédagogue faut beaucoup
concerter mais au final et on se le
disait avant l'émission souvent n'en
n'entend plus parler après
j'entendais donc le proviseur de ce
collège dire 30 100% une famille sur
trois environ est-ce qu'on a des
chiffres sur le la façon de contourner
la carte scolaire alors
dans le peu demander une dérogation
et que on a de moins en moins d'élèves
donc j'allais dire il serait facile
d'accorder des dérogations plus plus
largement ce qu'on ne fait pas c'est à
dire qu'il faut vraiment être très
attentif sur les demandes de dérogation
pour aller notamment dans un collège à
IPS plus fort le moyen qu'on a trouvé
finalement de faire en sorte que les
familles favorisées restent dans les
collèges plus défavorisés c'est
notamment à travers le bonus IPS qu'on
donne désormais au collégien pour être
affectés en lycée c'est-à-dire que vous
êtes collégien votre année de troisième
dans un collège moins favorisé à Paris
vous avez un bonus assez important qui
vous permettra d'être affecté plus
facilement dans le lycée de votre choix
et ça s'applique à toute une coord de
troisième que vous veniez d'une famille
favorisée ou défavorisée tout le monde a
ce bonus donc ça veut dire qu'à l'entrée
en 6e les familles qui seraient tentées
de se dire je suis dans un collège qui a
moins enfin je vais aller dans un
collège qui est moins bonne réputation
plutôt de CSP plus je vais pas faire le
choix du privé je vais pas demander une
dérogation et quatre ans plus tard je
choisirais plus facilement mon lycée
Xavier je connais beaucoup de parents
qui prônent des valeurs de tolérance de
mixité sociale mais qui vont tout faire
pour éviter un collège ghetto à leurs
enfants oui alors moi j'ai pas vraiment
le le mot ghetto mais effectivement
c'est c'est la question de la réputation
du collège parce que moi je le vois dans
mon département on a parfois des
collèges qui sont au cœur d'une cité HLM
qui ont une équipe pédagogique
fantastique qui ont un niveau plutôt
très correct au niveau des élèves mais
qui subissent en fait le fait d'être le
collège du quartier le collège de la
cité et donc il y a une forme
d'évitement et de demande de dérogation
pour aller dans le collège qui
effectivement en zone dense on est à 5
10 minutes à pied d'un autre collège
public et donc je pense que une des
mesures aussi pour pallier au-delà de
faire ces binômes de de collège c'est
avoir toutes les filières d'excellence
dans les collèges qui sont les moins
favorisés en tout cas dans qui sont qui
ont par exemple une réputation
internationale internationales les
horaires déménager les clashsham Chad
toutes ces classes aménagées qui
permettent en fait d'attirer un public
qui est plus attiré par l'option plutôt
que par le collège et du coup on crée
cette mixité il y a parfois nous on a
par exemple dans les Hauts-de-Seine la
filière la maîtrise la Maîtrise des
Hauts-de-Seine qui est donc une classe
musicale et donc c'est les classes qui
peuvent aller aussi dans des dans des
collèges de quartiers et qui permettent
d'attirer et qui fait de la qui font de
toute façon de la mixité sociale
automatique et ça je pense que c'est une
des solutions aussi pour pour les
collèges dit défavorisés est-ce que ça
marche ça Youssef swedy les par exemple
les collèges d'excellence assez
d'excellents
le contournement de la carte scolaire
quand on regarde qui va dans son collège
de secteur ou qui va dans un autre
collège public par dérogation ou dans un
collège privé on voit que au niveau
national c'est deux tiers des élèves qui
vont dans leur collège de secteur
donc ça rejoint à peu les chiffres 15%
dans un autre collège public et 22% des
un collège privé par contre si on
s'intéresse aux catégories sociales très
favorisées c'est seulement la moitié qui
vont dans leur collège de secteur et
plus on est favorisé plus on contourne
la carte scolaire est en train de nous
dire et par exemple dans une ville comme
Paris 50% des catégories sociales
favorisées vont dans un collège privé et
c'est une tendance qui qui s'accroît au
fil du temps ensuite pour revenir
également sur ces deux collèges là qui
ont été dans un binôme collège
berliozwalks le collège Berlioz vous
parlez des effets de réputation en fait
il a toujours quand même cette mauvaise
réputation qui traîne et il reste moins
favorisé que le collège d'à côté c'est
des effets qui qui restent au cours du
temps et c'est vrai que l'introduction
d'une section internationale ça peut
améliorer l'attractivité d'un collège
après il y a la question de la
ségrégation au sein de l'établissement
entre les différentes classes qui peut
se poser et intervenir c'est très vrai
cette question des moi j'appelle ça les
cursus haute valeur ajoutée ce qu'on met
comme ça les sections internationales
les classes Cham dans les dans les
établissements
je trouve c'est une excellente idée et
on la pratique maintenant il faut aussi
un choc d'attractivité c'est à dire que
si on met une classe isolée parmi on va
dire dans un collège difficile ça ne
marche pas donc il faut amener assez
massivement ces sections il faut pas une
section il en faut plusieurs par exemple
dans la clinique Paris
on va fermer un établissement à la
rentrée prochaine qui s'appelle le lycée
Brassens c'est Brassens il a un IPS de
154 donc c'est très élevé c'est
au-dessus c'est au-dessus d'Henri IV ou
tu le Legrand cet établissement
n'accueille que des élèves en double
cursus musique et dense l'air en horreur
aménagé en partenariat avec des grandes
institutions culturelles cet
établissement qui est un petit
établissement la présente de Région a
décidé de le fermer nous trans de ses
élèves et de ses formations à 10 minutes
au lycée Bergson qui a une pièce de 95
donc un moment donné on crée un
établissement qui est entre guillemets
un ghetto de pauvres ou de riche et
notamment à travers ses sections pour
l'amener dans un autre établissement
proche c'est aussi un moyen et de
l'amener massivement c'est à dire que
ces classes qu'on va amener massivement
seront plus nombreuses que les classeurs
binaires si je peux pas est-ce que je
peux me permettre de poser une question
du coup parce que est-ce que du coup la
baisse de la démographie
scolaire va pas inciter à créer cette
mixité en regroupant du coup des
établissements comme vous prenez cet
exemple là c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire que on ferme cet établissement mais
on ferme aussi des lycées professionnels
qui sont les plus pauvres de l'Académie
qui sont des petits établissements parce
que la baisse démographique est très
présente à Paris et on les emmène dans
des lycées ou l'IPS est plus élevé pour
terminer sur cette question de la carte
scolaire question à Gilles de Marquay je
reviens vers vous est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de parents d'élèves qui
viennent dans des établissements privés
avec cette motivation grise on cherche à
contourner la carte scolaire à échapper
un collège ou un lycée privé dans lequel
on veut pas que nos enfants arrivent
écoutez sur les motivations que peut
avoir les familles pourra se faire leur
enfant dans un ensemble un établissement
privé elle peut être complètement variée
elles peuvent être liées parce que c'est
aussi l'école de proximité elles peuvent
être liées au fait que elle cherche un
contexte ou l'enfant va être pris dans
sa l'intégralité dans sa globalité dans
toutes ses dimensions elles peuvent
chercher également des motifs religieux
il y en a encore bien évidemment elle
peut chercher aussi le fait que
on est des
un accompagnement parce qu'il y a un
projet éducatif qui correspond à son
enfant alors que l'établissement d'à
côté aura un projet éducatif un peu
différent qui correspondra à son autre
enfant donc on cherche tous ces
arguments moi je vais être très
transparent avec nos téléspectateurs moi
j'ai été dans le privé et mes enfants
étaient dans le privé donc vous voyez
j'ai pas de souci avec ça j'ai pas été
en situation de contourner une carte
scolaire ça a été un choix dès le départ
mais dans la liste que vous êtes en
train de nous faire pardon pour en avoir
discuté avec pas mal de copains il y a
aussi la volonté de contourner une carte
scolaire vous allez pas le nier
ça peut arriver bien évidemment pour
certaines familles mais ce ne pense pas
que ça soit la majorité loin de là alors
je récompense quand même du cas pas
Ndiaye du ministre de l'éducation
nationale parce que je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on s'attendait à des annonces
importantes aujourd'hui finalement bon
ça devient une boîte à outils j'adore le
bricolage mais c'est un peu moins
ambitieux qu'un plan sur la mixité
sociale Guillaume Le mise à l'éducation
c'est un peu une énigme politique et
pour certains une déceptions oui il fait
partie de ceux qui y compris au sein du
gouvernement se définissent eux-mêmes un
peu vous savez comme les invisibles de
ce gouvernement il y a même un dîner qui
aurait eu lieu avec plusieurs d'entre
eux notamment le ministre de la santé
c'est vrai qu'il fait partie de ces
ministres qui sont peu ou pas connus du
tout on pouvait être d'accord ou pas
avec son prédécesseur Jean-Michel
Blanquer mais c'est vrai que Jean-Michel
Blanquer avait su imprimer des marqueurs
politiques avaient su imprimer un style
des marqueurs politiques on le sait par
exemple sur la question de la laïcité ou
de la lutte contre le communautarisme
dans les établissements scolaires donc
ce longtemps effectivement y compris
dans le gouvernement à propos de papel
Ndiaye c'est quelqu'un de trop discret
qui n'incarne pas assez cette fonction
et c'est vrai que ça se retrouve
notamment dans les études d'opinion je
regardais avant l'émission le dernier
baromètre fait par l'Institut ipso pour
le journal Le Point qui paraît tous les
mois et bien dans ce baromètre le
ministre de l'Éducation arrive seulement
en 24e position derrière Gérard Larcher
avec seulement 18% d'opinion favorables
on peut dire qu'il n'est pas idée non il
n'est pas idée parce que les missions
faut bien le dire que le conflit le chef
de l'État sont parfois des missions
quasiment impossibles rappelez-vous il y
a quelques semaines quand sur le plateau
du 13h de France 2 et de TF1 le chef de
l'État a quasiment décrété qu'à la
rentrée prochaine il y aurait
systématiquement des remplaçants dans
tous les établissements ou les
professeurs seraient manquants bien sûr
on sait que ce sera pas possible comme
un claquement de doigts le problème
c'est que vous savez nos journalistes
évidemment à la rentrée on va aller
faire des reportages dans ces
établissements et il y a forcément
quelques-uns forcément quelques
établissements où ce sera pas tout de
suite en place d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'éducation Lady ce sera pas forcément
dès septembre ce sera peut-être un peu
plus tard le problème c'est que dans ces
cas-là celui qui sera tenu pour
responsable ce sera pas Emmanuel Macron
ce sera bien le ministre de l'Éducation
tout ça serait peut-être un peu moins
grave ce problème d'incarnation si on
était sur un sujet considéré comme
peut-être un peu moins important mais
c'est pas le cas l'éducation nationale
c'était un des thèmes prioritaire de la
campagne de réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
il y avait l'éducation et la santé
davantage même que la réforme des
retraites qui n'était pas assez un petit
peu derrière alors il y a quand même un
point positif à mettre à son crédit
c'est les relations avec les enseignants
qui sont clairement apaisés là où
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué sur ce
point là avec Jean-Michel Blanquer
Xavier pourquoi une peine à convaincre
ce ministre
je pense que c'est pas une question de
convaincre ou de notoriété je pense que
la priorité c'est de mettre en place le
programme présidentiel et de faire en
sorte que la priorité qui a été fixée
par le Président de la République
c'est-à-dire l'éducation et la santé
puis cette mise en œuvre
de la mixité sociale c'est peut-être
moins une priorité non non pas du tout
et l'assignation pardon en résidence et
les déterminants sociaux qui est qui la
lutte contre dirt sociaux qui ont été
une des priorités du précédent
quinquennat sont toujours la priorité
est toujours un prix de la priorité
pardon du président de la République et
la question de l'éducation de la mixité
sociale c'est toujours encore une fois
dans les priorités du président donc la
revalorisation par exemple des
enseignants que aucun enseignant
maintenant ne puisse commencer sa
carrière à moins de 2000 euros net le
nouveau pack pacte qui a été aussi
proposé aux enseignants pour avoir plus
d'horaires au service de l'éducation et
puis moi je pense qu'il faut aussi
revoir la question des programmes et ça
je le parle à titre personnel et pas au
nom ni de la majorité ni au nom du
gouvernement mais je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à revoir sur sur par
exemple l'enseignement des langues
vivantes c'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui
on soit un des pays où on parle moins
bien l'anglais ou il y a eu quelques
reportages d'ailleurs sur un enseignant
qui a qui a brûlé les copies du bac qui
c'est une pas acceptable mais ça montre
quand même un vrai problème dans notre
pays sur l'apprentissage des langues et
sur les programmes en général et donc il
faut pouvoir répondre à ça et
l'éducation nationale d'un vous le savez
mieux que moi c'est pas quelqu'un un
ministère qui est facile à réformer et
donc beaucoup de ministres se sont
cassés les dents dessus et donc je pense
qu'il faut y aller progressivement mais
il faut avoir une ambition pour notre
école parce qu'encore une fois je pense
qu'on ne peut pas se satisfaire de la
situation actuelle et tous les
programmes qu'on a mis en place depuis 6
ans maintenant vont dans l'amélioration
de la scolarité alors je vous propose
avant qu'on il nous reste trois quatre
minutes allez on va boucler avec un
deuxième extrait de du documentaire dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure donc ce
documentaire le collège d'à côté là
c'est la la CPE la concierge principale
d'éducation qui qui témoigne sur
finalement ce que ce que change la
mixité notamment pour les élèves moyens
dans une classe écoutée il est très bons
élèves peu importe l'endroit où tu
l'aimais ils seront toujours très bons
élèves donc l'inquiétude des parents sur
il va être moins bien moins bon moyen
il n'y a pas de sujet quoi il y a pas de
sujet les très très en difficulté ils ne
seront toujours un petit peu quoi ça
c'est sûr mais c'est pas grave comme la
classe ça plus calme on pourra
travailler avec différemment c'est ça
qui est intéressant et puis le gros du
du de la classe le le milieu ben on
s'aperçoit que finalement quand
l'ambiance est quand même beaucoup plus
sereine ceux qui ont tendance à pouvoir
avoir des problèmes de comportement être
moyen et avoir des problèmes de
comportement bah du coup ils vont être à
plus apaisés ils vont pouvoir être
concentré sur leur travail donc ce n'est
que bénéfique pour eux clairement je
voyais acquiescer c'est c'est quelque
chose que vous vous voyez sur le terrain
aussi c'est très vrai c'est à dire que
les bons élèves de toute façon
réussissent partout voilà et d'ailleurs
on parle toujours et je m'assure je
compte à cette expression de bons lycée
de bons établissements ou de mauvais
établissements il y a pas de bon ou de
mauvais établissements et des
établissements dans lesquels les bons
élèves se concentrent parfois et des
élèves plus en difficulté dans d'autres
mais les enseignants les programmes sont
les mêmes partout l'enseignant ne sont
pas nommés en fonction de leur mérite
mais en fonction de ancienneté
principalement donc les enseignants les
équipes sont bonnes partout avec des
difficultés partout également donc les
bons de toute façon réussiront ce qui
est important quand même de dire c'est
que les familles confondent parfois
l'exigence et la concurrence l'exigence
elle doit être partout dans
l'enseignement public dans tous les
établissements publics mais elle n'est
pas à confondre avec la concurrence que
réclame certaines familles qui veulent
que leurs enfants aille plus loin plus
haut que les autres et ça c'est autre
chose merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau ou en ou en duplex voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission je vous dis à
lundi pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public vous pouvez retrouver notre
émission et toutes les programmes de la
chaîne sur notre plateforme public
sénat.fr aller faire un tour elle est
toute neuve cette plateforme et ça
fonctionne très bien merci Guillaume à
bientôt sur ce